all right it's that time of the week for
audience questions you can submit these
really however you want tweet me at
Deepak Minh email Facebook Twitter
mentioned Twitter already Instagram I
don't know in any case every week I
answer three questions the first one
today is hey David who are going to be
the first Democratic candidates to drop
out of the 2020 race so the first
question is do you mean prominent or not
and if you do how do you define
prominent versus not prominent we've
already seen some people drop out so
former West Virginia Senator Richard O
jeddah who I interviewed has already
dropped out dropped out very very early
said he wasn't really able to raise
money so I guess I'll answer the
question as far as the slightly more
well known candidates although everybody
has a different sense of who kind of
counts because there are all sorts of
different people running as we found out
this week including with some of the
people that that we talk to so of the
people that I would consider relatively
prominent and that are at least
potentially showing up in polls although
in some polls they're polling zero which
isn't good I don't think Hickenlooper is
going to last
I don't think Kirsten Gillibrand is
getting any traction whatsoever and it's
really hard to imagine them making it
all the way to the first primaries
congressman Tim Ryan I like the guy I
met him interviewed him at Netroots
nation in New Orleans in August has a
lot of great ideas talking about stuff
that a lot of other members of Congress
don't talk about have a hard time seeing
how he gets any traction you're you're
already sort of seeing or maybe better
said not seeing him anywhere because
he's not getting any traction
Julian Castro entered the race early
he's getting very little traction but
he's at least getting 3% in some polls
and that gets me to Tulsi Gabbard Tulsi
has a very loud following but I continue
to see her not getting any traction
she's polling 0 or 1 in most polls she's
polling one percent in a new Emerson
national poll and Andrew yang who
started as a complete unknown without
even a
seat in the House of Representatives to
use as a sort of jumping-off point even
yang is polling 3% in this recent poll
compared to Tulsi Gabbard polling 1% now
I think that that's one that her
followers will disagree with me on
they'll say David as soon as the debates
start she's going to rock it up she has
made the debates so it's just a matter
of time for Tulsi Gabbard and we'll see
I mean I think there's no question Tulsi
is going to last longer than kirsten
gillibrand Hickenlooper and Tim Ryan but
it's not looking good for Tulsi and this
is not I'm not giving my opinions here
about who I like and don't like Tim Ryan
I really like interviewed him met him
very smart guy very knowledgeable guy
spoke after the interview with him about
economics and many other issues I'm just
going by the polls and by the media
stories that were starting to see and
that is there there's no indication
right now that Tulsi has the legs to
keep it going
Amy Klobuchar also unlit unlikely to
last very long jay inslee seems to be
going nowhere John Delaney is absolutely
going nowhere so from the people
currently running the ones with what I
see is sort of staying power these are
not again endorsements of who I like
just people who are getting traction in
a way that is fomenting or building a
campaign that is polling something at
this point in time you've got Bernie
you've got Beto O'Rourke again I'm not a
Beto fan but if you look at the polling
and the fundraising he's doing well at
this point in time Kamala Harris who is
not a super interesting candidate to me
then slightly in the kind of half tear
down would be Elizabeth Warren and Pete
Budaj edge has been getting attention
and has been rising in the polls and
then further down you see Cory Booker
and interestingly as I mentioned Andrew
yang who is polling three percent in
this new Emerson poll that came out
earlier this week but that is very
interesting given that Gillibrand is
polling zero in that one john delaney
polling one in that emerson poll and
Tulsi Gabbard polling
it is very interesting to see that
Andrew yang now is polling 3% and that
was a poll released before his CNN Town
Hall which was on Sunday night so those
are my thoughts in terms of who were
going to see go very soon who we are
unlikely to see make it all the way and
then who I see right now as the top
contenders and you know the great thing
I could be totally wrong because at this
point in time rarely does the leader
ultimately end up being the nominee and
everything I said could end up being
completely backwards which I think would
be something that will a pleasure
significantly the Tulsi Gabbard
followers who are either not believing
or very upset about her 0 to 1 percent
polling in almost every poll that is out
right now let me know what you think
where am I wrong where am i right